it is an
unbearable crime violence
r these crimes it is a shock for
everyone it is a blow against a
civilized society is a reaction of
absolute horror compared to this carnage which
comes to touch an organ of press
obviously very  well known in France
it is freedom that attacks and and if
we attack freedom everywhere in the
world we attack democracy
the horror once again it is here we are
obviously attacking a symbol of
freedom of expression  in our countries
we must avoid having
instinctive reflexes by saying morning we must
barricade ourselves we must barricade
democracy put it behind
barbed wire to be sure that it is
protected
figs and west in biel or horse racing
but also above all remain calm
a family and cameras that
cannot express themselves
we have attacked democracy in its heart
there is no question of declaring or
noting  the death of charlie today
we are all charline